okay audio synchronization time three
two
one three two one
brilliant it's not a little bit like
like a power rangers like audio
synchronization time
oh the worst power rangers ever the
power to synchronize audio
[Music]
so i've been doing animation on the web
for probably about 20 years now um
i used to write a library for it that
the bbc used back when i worked there uh
and i'd say more recently mostly
animation work i do is
like when i do slides for talks is kind
of one of the times i really throw
lots of weird animation effects and
stuff to kind of to try and keep people
awake while i'm droning on about
something
boring and standardly um
but i i don't normally give my
credentials up front like that but the
reason i'm doing that now is because
i still get caught out by loads of
animation stuff on the web
i think it's really hard and i think
some of the
tools we have at our disposal are not so
great um
and could be a lot better yeah this this
this rings
very much to them for me true to home
sort of thing i think i just miss
english either way but yeah i remember
when we were writing procs
that i had to write like an animation
library for the canvas-based animations
and you were like
i've done this before let me tell you of
all the struggles you're gonna encounter
yes exactly um so let's talk about two
relatively basic animations fading
something in you just saw that there
and fading something out there you go
but even those have a ton of complexity
and gotchas um
yeah i i only feel like i'm starting to
come to some conclusions of how
these basic animations should be done in
a way that's safe and avoids all of the
gotchas
i would say way back when i would use um
jquery or green sock or the library i
wrote um
i used green sock because i used to be a
flash developer i don't know if i've
mentioned that enough times but uh
that's that green sock was a
an animation library for flash that then
moved to the web so i kind of i used
that for a bit
but then we got these things
css transitions so the older animation
libraries were just changing inline
styles over time
either by using set timeout or later
request animation frame which would be
the proper way of doing it but with this
you've got compositing and the animation
happening off the main thread
so like your opacity and transforms even
if your main thread is janky these
animations will run nice and smooth
pretty good for things like cover
effects because no javascript needed
there you go
you can you know throw out your jquery
and your green sock or whatever
and that's what i did enough i'm just
going to use these this is it from now
on
but i was also using javascript for
interactions
so i wanted to drive transitions with
javascript
so the user clicks a button now i want
the new thing to fade in
so i'm going to create it give it an
opacity of zero
add it to the document and then
transition it to full opacity
cool yeah yeah cool yeah
no go on tell me about it
we i the only reason i know this is
because we actually
had a question about this i think on the
first big web quiz
at some point yeah and then we started
testing and discovered that browsers
were still having
behaving differently here actually so i
think because you know this is
all javascript there is no yielding to
the browser between the append
and the subsequent changes of the style
so the browser
the the rendering engine only sees that
the transition
and an opacity of one because the
previous change is invisible to the
rendering engine
spot on yes absolutely um the browser
never sees the opacity zero never thinks
about it in terms of styling
it's just a javascript value and it's
overridden before it thinks about
styling anything
so the way you work around this is
either by
waiting until the next frame which means
using requestanimationframe twice
of course it's twice because
requestanimationframe is
before the next frame so if you want to
push into the next frame you have to use
it twice
or you hack around it so all i'm doing
here is using get computer style
and just calling get computer style is
not enough
you have to then read a property from it
and that is when the browser will
think about the style and it thinks
about that opacity zero
and then it will transition to one
fine okay let's fade something out
there we go pretty good good start
um but what if
like opposite to before i want to remove
it
once it's faded out so let's give that a
go
you get an event so there we go job done
can you see the gotcha here
uh
actually i cannot and not even die for a
long time
uh until it caught me out and it's that
events bubble
so i could get this event not for when
my transition finishes
but from when some other thing finishes
its transition
and once you start getting into more
complex transitions where
like something inside fades out slightly
sooner you start finding your
things disappearing from the document
much sooner because you're actually
catching that event from another
animation so
so you should check for yes yeah
so that caught me out as well but if
that element was already
zero opacity you get no transition
so you don't get an event which is great
so now if you're building a sort of more
generic animation system that's
something you have to check
because people will say like try you
know make this go to zero and then
remove it
and if it's already zero they just want
it to be removed
um this kind of code is extremely
fragile
because you're checking you know you'll
be checking what the input value
versus uh the computed value but
even with opacity zero percent and zero
are the same thing the computed value
will always come out as zero
but the user of the library might have
given you zero percent
um you're not going to get a transition
from those two because they compute to
the same value
and we don't have the tools to easily
convert
arbitrary values into compute values
also if it's displaying on
or it's inside an element that's
displaying on or it's not in the
document
you're not going to get a transition
event so
this this is just not going to work
properly so we'll throw all of that out
and start again what i'm going to do
this time
is use css animations because this
arrives slightly later
um than transitions but you know we've
had them for
at least a decade now i i'd say this
just works
so i'm you know setting the opacity
and then it's animating from opacity 0
to its computed style which is going to
be
one and i don't have to do any computed
style hacks
this will just work which is great yeah
this is my current
go go-to preference for making things
appear
when added can get when they get added
to the dom just like it automatically
plays
just place once it stops at the end
it's brilliant which is great isn't it
because you we're now in a situation
where it's easier to use css animations
for transitions than css transitions
great excellent but yes i agree with you
this is
moving towards how i do things with
animations these days
so what about the fade out and remove
that's a you know slightly different
model
uh so i'm going to add another keyframe
animation this time
fading out and off we go like we still
need to deal with the bubbling still
have the event bubbling issue
but this time it's fine if the value is
the same so if you're animating from
opacity 0 to opacity 0
you'll still get the event which is
great oh really
yes i did not know that you won't get it
if it's displayed on or inside an
element that's displaying on so
you know we're making steps forward but
we're not there yet
but then enter the web animations api
this just works which is great
so i'm saying like providing my
one and only keyframe which is opacity
zero and i give it an offset zero which
means that this keyframe is at the start
of the animation the offset is between
zero and one and off it will animate it
will animate from
opacity 0 to whatever the style resolves
at which would be
one by default but it could be something
else so this works in those cases as
well
does this currently work in chrome this
exact syntax yes it does
yeah so what you're thinking there is
like and for a long time
you had to specify at least two key
frames um yeah
you don't anymore this just works it
will figure out the other one
automatically which is great i wish it
was there from the start
it wasn't but yeah this works now and
it's well supported
right the web animation api is if you're
targeting modern browsers
it's everywhere like it arrived to
safari
more recently than the others but it's
there now so this is how i do animations
now
well it shows that chrome supported web
animations ati from 44 to 84 but i think
that wasn't
complete support right so that that
table seems to be a tiny bit misleading
that's true um so in terms of the
multiple keyframe thing i think it was
actually firefox that landed that first
so credit to them but yeah chrome
supports it now
so yes although that chart shows
everything looking good
for a long time in chrome there are
features that i'm showing today that
arrived
in between then and i didn't
look up when so don't ask me but it's
been in they've been in chrome for
multiple versions now so they're safe to
use
so what about fading out um there you go
that's it
uh javascript animations stay finished
even if it's display non
or if it's not in the document so you
don't have to overcome that as well
actually there is a bug here in chrome
of course there is yeah bloody chrome
spoiling all that fun the promise
resolves too late
so the the animation will finish
uh and then sometime later the promise
resolves which if you're doing accurate
animation work this is far too late
so instead of the promise use the events
this is fixed in canary so
um it's on its way to stable but
you know that's a workaround that works
today i want to talk about more gotchas
what if i wanted to fade something from
whatever it is now to not point to
opacity
and leave it i'm not going to remove it
from the document
something like this can you see the
gotcha
um
i mean i'm i'm immediately drawn to just
one keyframe where
i don't know if it's implicit that's at
the end of the animation
if you just specify one keyframe that's
a good point uh yes it is
like but if you provide one keyframe it
implies the end keyframe
for some reason okay so they got you
here and i don't see it
yeah and i mean if you ran this code you
would see it immediately because here's
what it does
the animation ends and then the
animation is gone
so everything that the animation was
affecting stops being affected
so yeah that's why i usually i almost
always define the fill
behavior because i just don't trust the
defaults
there we go job done fill forwards
and yeah now it works so just to be
clear that means
when the animation ends in the timeline
you have keyframes and you play from one
key to the next
phil tells you what happens when the
time is outside
these two keyframes should you loop
should you
fill or there's probably others as well
but yeah that's what this
property does looping is different it's
it's forwards and backwards and both
are the values so yes if you have an
animation that is delayed
um a fill of backwards
means it will apply the first keyframe
while it's waiting for the animation to
start
a fill of forwards means that once the
animation is done
it will hold the last state both does
both
but i have come to the conclusion that
this is
a huge gotcha and every time i have done
this
it has bitten me at some point later on
especially if i'm doing something a
little bit more complicated
and it's because of this it doesn't work
like the animation has higher priority
oh
because the animation is technically
still running i guess
effectively it's still held and while an
animation is running or
in while it's still happening to some
extent
it has priority over almost everything
um the only thing it doesn't have
priority over is
um important styles you know when you do
exclamation important
it doesn't have priority over that but
yes if your solution is to use
important styles you've done something
wrong earlier on right so
we need to fix this some of the way and
actually like
there's a method which i'm going to
struggle to remember like
document.getanimations
you will see all of these animations
that have filled forwards
so anything that ever ran essentially is
going to be in there
oh that i didn't know that one that's
neat
yes uh because like in css you will
remove that animation by removing the um
the style resolution which has the the
animation property on it
so if you remove that class name then it
removes the animation
with web animations you need to
deliberately cancel the animation
if you wanted that um so what's the
answer
and it's taking me years to figure out
and so i might still be wrong
um but here's what i've here's the
conclusion that i've come to
so strapping just don't animate ever
don't animate it's awful people hate it
no i'm going to make an animate 2
function which takes the elements
and then the the animation arguments see
on the keyframes and the options
i'm going to create the animation and
return it so this will run to completion
and then snap back to the start values
as we saw before
so we're going to fix that i'm going to
create finish events
i could use the promise except for
chrome that bug
so i'm going to use the events and then
i'm going to call
commit styles this is an api that not
many folks
seem to know about what it does is it
commits
inline styles for the animation at its
current position
so you can call this multiple times in
the animation and it will just like dump
out
inline styles for whatever's happening
right now
there's a problem here though because
the current position is finished so
everything has already snapped back to
the start so this doesn't work
there is a spec disagreement on this
already that like
maybe that shouldn't be the behavior
maybe this should just work
if you call it after it's finished it
will give you the final styles but
that's not the way browsers behave
so i'm going to add phil both and i know
i said that was bad
and it is but we need it so we have
those styles when the animation ends
and then once committed cancel the
animation which removes it from the
queue
and you end up with the inline styles so
you've got that that it's held the final
position
but it means that you can update inline
styles later on and it will all work
and for the people already wondering i'm
pretty sure this event listener doesn't
leak
no because it fires once and then it the
browser knows it's not going to
be fired again especially once the
animation is
garbage collected so the animation can't
be restarted because animation can get
garbage collected yeah
yeah i guess the listener could leak if
you if you're holding onto the animation
object because you could restart the
animation
and in which case you could get finished
again but
yeah it's otherwise fine it's not
something to worry about
my previous solution to this was to um
apply the inline styles manually
uh on the on the and i wouldn't use fill
uh at all
because i hate it but this this raises a
question about composited animations
that i've seen browser folk argue about
so if you've got an animation that
completes
you get your finish event and then you
set the inline styles
what if your main thread is blocked at
that point and the animation is
happening on the compositor
some people would argue that the
animation would complete snap back
to the original values and then sometime
later you get your event
so you would still have a visual flicker
like animation completes it snaps back
and then you apply the inline styles
i couldn't get any browser to actually
do this so it seems like it's a it's a
bug they've
solved or worked around in some way but
that is not in the spec at all
so hmm maybe that will change in future
i mean it would make sense to
to set to somehow tie the value that the
animation
object is representing to the time that
the event
is being processed or the event is
created and put in the event queue
but yeah that definitely something that
needs to be specified and written down
that that is how it's supposed to behave
and even if the values are synchronized
it it's more about what you're seeing on
the screen
that you need then yes in crowds and
what it seems like browsers do is they
run the animation
on the compositor so off the main thread
but then the removal of the animation
where it would snap back
to the start point that is still handled
on the main thread
so that means that you get your events
in synchronization with that
thing happening but there's no spec for
how the compositor works
but browsers seem to be doing the right
thing but to defend against
changes in terms of how the compositor
works with the main thread
this code will defend against that
because it it's going to use that fill
forwards
or fill both in this case to hold that
final frame until your javascript gets
to run and it's your javascript which
removes the animation from the queue
there you go like 20 years
it's taken me to get to this combination
of
my own learning and also features being
and you know what you had to use phil
in the end after all after all but there
is
discussions in the spec to avoid having
to do this where if you call commit
styles at the end
in the finish event it will apply the
final styles which
that's just what i want that's what i
always wanted
just make that easy for me please but in
the meantime i
at least now have a simple small
function
that does exactly what i want
and that's all i've got
i having fiddled with writing
an animation engine which makes it sound
way more fancy
way fancier than it was in prox um
i appreciate this the simplicity of what
you boiled it down to so i'll
put it in a gist i might want to copy it
i'll yes i'll link to it in the
description along with the various bugs
and
spec bits and arguments and stuff that
are happening
and i'll put that uh yeah down in the
description
[Music]
it's loaded did you clap that second
time
yeah it's just perfectly insane my
earphones
maybe the sound well maybe the gbc
swallowed it yeah probably i could see
that happening